but your family's coming how do you feel
about that
so I know coming you coming everyone
doesn't know if people know you don't
know all right
Calathes sister essentially it's another
biological sister but it's a sister they
grew up together and she was her sister
and her kids and her sisters husband
they're coming up to America for the
first time a very crazy right and you
know where they're from they're from the
island of Cebu it's you have beautiful
malls there's there's resemblances of
America in Cebu Pizza great great
beaches great beaches great people but
you know America is gonna be a shock to
them I think they've just never left the
country before so imagine spending
40-something years in the same country
and then your first time out of the
country is to Los Angeles not just any
part of America but this like diverse
you know metropolis yeah as big as la is
well when you when you because I just
flew in this morning from Dallas when
you fly in it looks like you're flying
into the Death Star the surface of the
death starts gray light it's just
endless buildings of grey it's really
probably intimidating for anyone that
fly in here so Bobby and I have made a
list of places where we think they would
enjoy mostly just food places they would
like to book at the bat ball they would
like subway they would like anything you
just have subway though yeah but you
know they live in the provincial area of
Cebu yeah like in the other side of Cebu
like closer to the beaches and stuff so
as much as they have you know access to
you know modern things it's still really
I mean I could essentially take him to
Olive Garden for a whole two months and
they'd be so happy how they're gonna be
over two months no no her husband and
them only for two weeks but then the
girls for two months all the girls are
gonna be able to so I'm taking them to
San Francisco too well I have to take
him to Vegas because my mom's like you
have to pick them they're all mine
and I'm taking them I don't know I
haven't decided if I'm taking them to
New York
speaking of which yeah we're official
we're going to New York
oh well our belly is going to need oh
yeah I know we can announce it okay we
got announce it yeah so this is good
news guys tiger belly was invited to the
vulture fest Wow
and last year with over the years
they've had Natalie Portman Amy Amy
Poehler I mean just so many people get
invited to this thing and when I got the
call the other day last week
that they're interested in us I felt
like it put Tiger belly on the [ __ ]
map and like and let and listen to you
George you [ __ ]
you ugly piece of [ __ ] and you too you
ungrateful Brown [ __ ] yep
that then when they go will you can it
be - I know it's gotta be all at all of
them they never actually asked for - I
know about just saying it just trying to
make you feel bad [ __ ] me just now no
Eve doesn't matter that's what I wanted
to do we were feeling bad and you ruined
yeah would you do that why do you do
that like when I do like when I do an
improv out in the public she'll like
break the improv right away like exam
because people are suffering exam I love
suffering example please
oh no I'll just say something like yeah
you know I have three weeks to live and
then someone is like sincerely believing
in their good soul yeah and they're
crying have them in the pomp get to that
point yeah and then all the sick no he
doesn't he's lying yeah I have to or if
I do an accent at a restaurant hello oh
yeah yeah yeah
no I have up yeah I mean Bobby Bobby
just speaking your normal voice because
he does this thing where if we're the
for instance we went to Joshua Tree yeah
he thought that he needed to take on a
desert alter-ego the desert alter-ego
has nothing to do with the desert it was
like a Western John Wayne like and he
was like can I get a burrito after she
and I kept doing it and she was just
like stop it stop because everyone in
the we went to a Mexican restaurant
yeah and it was I mean it's still Joshua
Tree there's like they have things there
yes sir I have to do the desert Bob
cowboy what's desert Bob why did you
know man
Red Dead Redemption can I have some
taquitos chimichenga no and then they
they look at me and they go and then
she'll still [ __ ] it up I well I didn't
say anything that time that time you
didn't know sued you should just join in
have you ever thought of that
yeah but you know next time I tell a
friend like my mom died left true let me
just stew it for a bit I know that's
wrong you know I did something when I
was a young and I thought it was funny
and in retrospect I I can't even say it
now I feel so bad about it tell us I
told somebody I had AIDS I was like
maybe 22 mmm as a joke and he likes and
they were like look so sorry and I go
I'm kidding
like thinking that was funny which is
not it's not it's not funny at all but I
just feel bad about it still to this day
I didn't know why did never friends
again yeah yeah like that's it a single
lie that you have continued to tell well
I've never done a statement as is Eli
like I was in pro I want a man wanna
tell people I was in Pearl Harbor that's
fine but I'm a little smaller like a
small lie that you've told that you just
cannot stop telling because it's like
now it's even you believe it
you've ever done that when you've said
it for so long that you're like oh my
god I guess I did go through that I
think I do have yeah I have a bunch but
I want to say it now yeah I know I know
which ones they are to I'm so curious
yeah ever know you'll never know that's
good no no no I'm not even doing off the
record if you ever bring it up again
yeah it's gonna be a perfect problem
serious yeah I have a couple of things
that I'm a liar he's it spy or
I like the wind already sent two people
join up it's part of your persona
persona and I like to win and they're
innocent lies yummy they add their you
know the shadowplay I add to the
mystique of the celeb King and sometimes
you know I lie and you know what babe
you you've got it wrong
Oh God you got wrong there are truths in
these lines but I've exaggerated that so
much that they've turned um weird in my
mind or mine they turn gray a little bit
well great look great little grants the
white yeah
[Music]